what's up guys I'm here with Alan Hawk
himself what's up man how are you doing
I'm good good so you played Aquaman on
Smallville you've played Hawk now so
what does it like to play these iconic
heroes in the DC Universe it's it's good
man I mean it's tough because
everybody's got their preconceived
notion as to who this guy should be and
you're either you know supporting their
expectations or you're subverting it and
and I don't know it's hard to do both
you know so it's it's fun for me because
it's like it's you know it's always nice
to explore something that's like it's
been around for a long time and you know
maybe my kids will hold on to someday
you know but but there's a little
pressure there with it you know so I've
learned I think through my experience on
Aquaman just dive into the material and
do the best you can with with you know
the script and your surroundings and
circumstances and you know your best
shot that's all you can do you'd be
happy with your own and you killed it as
Aquaman you killed it as talk to you
what was your favorite episode so far
that you've shot my favorite episode is
episode 10 we come back and and you get
to meet Hawk and doves origin you know
stories so it's the genesis of how they
meet and how they become who they are in
the beginning in episode of two when we
meet Hawk and Dove in the series so we
dive in a subject matter that's like
I've never gotten to do as an actor and
it's something it's the kind of stuff I
wish we would talk about more on TV and
I think it took a lot of guts for the
network and for Akiva and Jeff and
everybody who wrote it and brought that
thing to life to to make that and talk
about the stuff that we talked about but
you get to know his past you get to know
Dawn's past and
it was tough it was tough to film and
been emotionally draining but but so
satisfying to like bring that story to
life because I think it's hopefully a
source of like healing and conversation
for a lot of people
so anyway I'm proud of that I can't wait
for people to see that that our show
goes places that nobody would expect I
know there were talks earlier about a
hot and dusty potential spin-off show
would would you still be interested in
doing something like that or would you
want to guest star on other shows like
VIN Patrol or anything like that yeah
I'd be I mean I'm a huge fan of this
whole universe you know so the more I
can do to be a part of it and explore
those different worlds and be down I
mean it is gonna take a toll on the body
I can tell you that his heart gets his
ass kicked she's like the only one
without a superpower so you know he's
just fighting with his fists and limping
away you know which is one of my
favorite things about him but it you
know like it takes its toll so it'll be
rough but I'll do it you know you've got
Aquaman you've got hog is there any
other DC characters that you would like
to potentially play down the road or
just in general I mean you know
Superman's cool like that's the one that
you know I grew up with you know always
wanted to be Superman so but I've been
Zack is everybody right everybody was
assuming this like what do you want
you're super proud of me like everybody
wants to be invisible where does
everybody want to fly
oh I think I'd be rotation teleportation
okay that's pretty good through time too
oh I knew think about that that's that'd
be my okay teleportation to trauma yeah
yeah and I've asked all the cast is Ryan
already disappointed me but I know pizza
how do you feel about that
you said pineapples don't keep no
pineapples on pizza oh I think mine
apples don't keep okay good throw some
way yeah hell no - pineapples on pizza
no no Ryan said yes pineapple in your
yogurt man you put pepperoni on your
pizza what's wrong with you people
listen to him alright thank you so much
man thank you
you